Take a look and examine the legs of the model. I expect you'll see some odd
shading on them. If you make the headlight brighter, the effect will become
more obvious. Moving the spot like this is likely to shift these patterns
around. The shadow mapping algorithm works by seeing the world from the lights
point of view. The depth image form is then checked during normal rendering.
The depth of the surface visible at a point is compared with the transformed
depth of the shadow map buffer holds. And that's where all the trouble begins.
The pixels in the Light's image of the world don't exactly match-up with those
in the Camera's view. These cause some form of what's called Surface Acne,
where little dark dots or patches appear in areas that should be fully lit.
Take this example. The Light's view of the surface says that it's 3.80 meters
away from the light. The Camera's view of the surface says that the location is
3.81 meters away from the light. Since this value is slightly higher than the
Light's view. The surface is considered in shadow. The surface is something
that should be impossible. It shadows itself, as the depths don't compare as
well as we would like. Here's a demo showing the problem, as well as a partial
solution. On these surfaces, you can see patterns of acne, where the geometry
is shadowing itself. One obvious solution is to add some tolerance value,
called the shadow bias. If the cameras computed distance along the lights view
plus this bias is less than the lights depth, then consider the surface lit.
Unfortunately, a simple bias leads to another problem called Peter Panning.
Just like Peter Pan the object starts to look as if it's detached from its
shadow and sometimes as if it's hovering above its true location. In the 35 or
so years this algorithm has been around, many different solutions have been
proposed to this problem. There are other problems with shadow mappings. Such
as the edges of the shadows looking pixelated. And solutions such as percentage
cluster filtering and cascaded shadow maps. I won't explain these here except
to say that 3JS has both of these solutions built in.